ก็
สวัสดีค่ะพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะน้องเรียงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนเย้
น้องเรียววันนี้เราเจอกันวันอะไรคะวันนี้
เตรียมกับพี่เอ๋เจอกันวันเสาร์วันเสาร์นะ
คะที่นี่ก็ได้นะจุ๊
กกุ๊กแปลว่า
หากอยู่ปฏิทิน
สวัสดี
มันเบลอค่ะยังไงหรอคะไม่เห็นมันเบลอ
เดี๋ยวนะคะงั้นครูเอ๋เอาอันนี้ออก
โอเคเห็นหรือยังคะโอเคเห็นแล้วค่ะเสร็จ
แล้วนะคะวันนี้วันเสาร์เห็นไหมกวนๆ
คะใช่ค่ะอันเสาร์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
10 น้ำเผาเดี๋ยวนะ
ผิดเดือน
โอเคเอ้านะคะวันที่
18  8  18 นะคะ 18 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
ธันวาคมเดือนธันวาคมปีพตตปีคศเท่าไหร่คะ
ข้อ
2010  21 ค่ะสัมพันธ์ 21 ปีพตพศศอศ
2564 ค่ะ
โอเคตอนนี้เวลา
ตอนนี้เวลา
นี่ดูสิคูเอกอะไรเฮ้ย
แต่ 03:00 น 03:00 โมงรู้ย
[เพลง]
ค่ะวันนี้
วันนี้นี่วันที่ 18 ใช่ไหมคะใช้ค่ะเดี๋ยว
นะคะครูเอ๋ดู
18 แล้วก็
19  20  21  22 เขต 1  2  3  4  5  6  7
8  9  10  11  12  13
อีกทีอีก 13 วัน
epp
2021 จะไป
ใช่ค่ะตีใหม่
ปีใหม่มีกับเปลี่ยนเปลี่ยนเป็น
2022 ที่
2022 ก็ต้องมีของขวัญที่ของขวัญของขวัญจ
4 คู่เอกก็มีคือเรียง
หัวกล้องของขวัญของครูเอกป่าแล้วมีมีนัก
เรียนส่งมาให้
หมอว้าวนักเรียนนักเรียนส่งมาแล้วก็ส่ง
ข้อความที่ LINE ครูเอ๋
รักของขวัญด้วย
รักของขวัญ
คู่เอกแกะกล่องของขวัญแล้วมีริบบิ้นก็แกะ
ออกแล้ว
ง้อกูเรียมเดาคิดคิดๆอะไร
ไหล่คะอะไหล่กล่องของขวัญข้างในข้างในมี
อะไร
[เพลง]
อะไรอะไรอะไรอะไร
ข้อสอบติ๊กต๊อกติ๊กต๊อกเลี่ยมคิดว่าเป็น
กระเป๋า
เล็กๆเป็นกระเป๋า
อาคือไม่ใช่
ให้เอกข้างติ๊กต๊อกติ๊กต๊อก
น่า
อะไรไกลนะอะไรนะอะไรนะ
อะไรขนมขนมมากินคุกกี้ใช่มั้ยปลุกที่
ไม่ใช่ค่ะ
อะไรคะเรื่องกับยูทู้ปอยากรู้และเปิดให้
ดู
ว่า x แกะกล่องแกะแล้วจับแล้ว
ก็แกะดึง
ก็แกะกล่องเนี่ยออกมา
แล้วก็ดึงออกมาแล้ว
เป็นอันนี้ถ้าอะไรคะ
กล้อง
กล้องอะไรอ่ะกล้องสำหรับทำวีดีโอให้
กล้องสำหรับคอมพิวเตอร์สำหรับสูงนะคะออ
โต้โฟกัส HD  webcam
เค้าว่าเค้าคู๋จะมองใหม่
เพราะว่าที่นี่คอมพิวเตอร์กล้องไม่ชัดเออ
เวลากูเอ๋แล้วก็ไม่ชัดใช่เวลาทอดตอนนี้
ตอนนี้ 03:00 นโอเคถ้า 5 โมงคู่เรียมจะ
ไม่เห็นครูเอ๋อ๋ออ๋อ 17:00 นเดือนมองไม่
เห็นพี่เก๋ให้เพราะว่ามันงวดจะราคามันจะ
เป็นแบบนี้แหละ
โอ้วห้าโมงเนี่ยคู๋แบบนี้
ตอนนี้ 03:00 นโอเค
3 โมงครูเอกก็ยังสว่าง
อ๋อ
สว่างเชื้อ
ใช่ค่ะระหว่างโอเคถ้าเกิด 17:00 นรู้ a
ก็จะ
คุยอีกจะเป็นแบบนี้แล้วค่ะ 5 โมงนี่ปลื้ม
จะแบบนี้เลย 5 โมงนักเรียน
แล้วถ้าเกิดเป็นทุ่มนึงล่ะคะ
มันก็จะแบบนี้เลยโอ้โห
แบบนี้เลยค่ะจะเป็นแบบเหมือนมีอะไรอยู่
เนี่ยไม่
โอเค
กล้องที่คอมพิวเตอร์ไม่โอเคดีไม่ดีก็เลย
ได้กล้องใหม่ค่ะเดี๋ยวครูเอ๋ลองเปลี่ยนนะ
คะเพราะกล้องคอมพิวเตอร์ถ้าครูเอ๋ใส่ไหม
ลาว
เป็นเบลอๆ
ไม่เห็นใช่มั้ยไม่เห็นอาหารไม่เห็นอะไร
เลยเดี๋ยวคู่ f เปลี่ยนกล้องนะคะขอ
เปลี่ยน
เปลี่ยนปล้อง
กับตั้งก่อนนักเรียน
เกิดการป้องกัน
กล้องจะลงหรือ
คิดว่าโอเคแต่กูอ่ะลองเปลี่ยนกล้องนะลอง
เปลี่ยนดูนะคะ
ว้าวโอเคไหมโอเคไหมคะนักเรียนเมื่อกี้
มั้ยเมื่อกี้กูเองทำต้องพูดมือใช่ไหมโอ้
โหโอเคมั้ยเรียมคิดว่าอุ้ยดีขึ้นดีใช่ไหม
คืนเห็นมือนะ
ว้าวกูจะเลยค่ะ
OK ชัดนะคะชัดค่ะชาติมองเห็นชัดมองเห็น
ชัดดูปากครูชัชชนัยค่ะ
ของขวัญค่ะ
เย้
ครูเอ๋ได้รับ
ขอบคุณค่ะ
ครูเอ๋ได้รับของขวัญมาแล้วลู่เหสโอ๊ะงของ
ขวัญให้คนอื่นบ้างไหมคะกูเองอะอา
ตอนนี้ไม่ได้ส่งเพราะว่าครูเอ๋ชอบให้เป็น
คุกกี้เป็นขนมกินได้เออเพราะโควิชคุณครู
เอกชาติเอาแล้วก็ไปต๊อกๆๆที่บ้าน
เดี๋ยวฉันนะคะก็ Share  screen นิดนึง
ที่นี่ใช่ไหมค่ะ
ถ้ามีที่นิ
สีดำดีกว่าเนาะ
สีดำบ้าน
ที่บ้านนี่ไม่ใช่วัดบ้าน
ที่บ้านประตูคุณเอ๋ชอบที่เนี่ยแล้วก็
ชอบชอบถือหรือของขวัญ
หมอคุกกี้
ก๊อกๆๆๆ
แล้วก็สวัสดีปีใหม่ค่ะสวัสดีปีใหม่ให้
ด้วยตัวเองก็ขอแบงค์
อาคูเรียมนะคะให้ของขวัญไหม
โหเรียมให้ของขวัญแต่ว่าเรียงส่ง
ไปรษณีย์
เตรียมไม่ได้เจอเดินไปที่บ้านแล้วก็ต้อง
สวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีปีใหม่ถ้าเกิดบ้านบ้าน
อยู่ใกล้ๆกันเค้กไล่กันโอเคเตรียมก็เดิน
เดินเอาของขวัญให้สวัสดีปีใหม่ค่ะ
โอเคแต่ว่าถ้าเกิดบ้านอยู่ทะเลไกล
ใกล้ๆก็จะส่งไปรษณีย์
สมุดบ้านเพื่อนอยู่เชียงใหม่
คูเรียมอยู่ที่ไหนหาสารคาม
มหาสารคามก็ครูเรียมจะขับรถไปเชียงใหม่
โอเคมั้ยไม่โอเค
ก็เลยใส่กล่องมีแต่กล่องแล้วก็ส่งส่งไป
เชียงใหม่ส่งที่ไหนอ่ะคะส่งที่อาไปสนิท
โทรศัพท์ได้ใช่ไหม
โทรศัพท์ก็ได้นะคะค่ะงูแต่ว่าขอคู่เอกเคย
เห็นอันนี้ไหมคะอะไรค่ะ
อะไรโอ้ยแบบนี้
ถ้าขอ
เป็นมีรถ
ใช่ค่ะมีมีรถมอเตอร์ไซค์
สีสีม่วง
ให้แล้ว
สีม่วงไหมม่วงสิลทมอ่าใส่สีม่วง
รถมอเตอร์ไซค์ที่เขาแบบนี้มึนๆสีม่วงที่
คนขับรถเอสไอมีหมวดใช่หามีหมวกกันน็อค
หมวกกันน็อกหมวกกันน็อคด้วย
[เพลง]
ก็มีรถแล้วข้างล่างอะไรคะก็มีรถนะข้าง
ล่างก็เป็นรถ
รถที่ว่ารถส่งของรถส่งของนะคะใช่ค่ะก็จะ
เอาของขวัญนี้นะคะไปส่ง
ส่งถูกที่เชียงใหม่
ไปเชียงใหม่ได้ค่ะถ้าอันนี้ก็จะเป็นคนส่ง
ของค่ะแล้วก็ชุดสีแดงนี้คนอะไรคะรับคนที่
รักเสร็จงานก็คือคนรับเงือกเป็นเป็นผู้
เราบอกว่าผู้รับใช่ไหมได้ค่ะคนไทยจะเรียก
ว่าผู้รับผู้รับแต่ว่าคนที่ใส่เสื้อ
แขนสั้นสีแดงแขนสั้นนะคะแล้วก็เสื้อเสื้อ
การ์ดสีน้ำเงินอันนี้คือเสื้อการ์ดนะคะ
นักเรียน
เลิกกากค่ะก็คือ
ขนาดงานส่งของพนักงานส่งของนะคะให้
กับเวลาส่งของครูเรียม
เขียนอะไรไหม
เขียนค่ะต้องเขียนอ้าต้องต้องพอมีกันนี้
เป็นกล่องของใช่ไหมคะจะต้องมีมีมี
ขอถุงใส่นิกล่องใส่เอกใช่ไหม
ใช่ค่ะมีกล่องใส่กล่องใส่แบบนี้
ต่อ
กล่องใส่แบบนี้อันนี้คือกล่อง her เป็น
กล่อง
ใช่ค่ะคนไทยเรียกว่ากล่องพัสดุกล่องพัสดุ
เพราะว่าของเป็นพัสดุ
ถ้าเป็นแบบนี้เป็นซอง
จดหมายนะคะ 2 จดหมายอ่า
เห็นไหมค่ะเห็น
กฎหมายโอเคส่งส่งพัสดุ
หรือส่งจดหมายนะคะใช่ค่ะกล่องนี้
เอ๋คะโอเคค่ะฮะโอเค
อุบัติเหตุ
โอเคโอเค
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
กล่องมันชนวางก่อนโอเคถ้ากล่องแบบนี้
เตรียมก็ส่งเป็นกล่องพัสดุ
ไปค่ะส่งเป็นพัสดุแต่ถ้าเกิดครูเอ๋มีส่ง
การ์ดปีใหม่ไหมคะ
ปีใหม่เมื่อก่อนค่ะตอนนี้ครูเอ๋ขี้เกียจ
คู่เอกก็ส่งการ์ดออนไลน์ออก Art  Online
ใช่ไหมคะเขียนเขียนข้างในว่า Happy  New
Year อะไรได้เป็นการ์ดออนไลน์อ่า
ไม่แพง
การ์ดเนี่ยก๊าบ
A31 ใบน่ะ
100 บาท 200 บาทแต่เวลาส่งใช่ไหมคะเวลา
การไปน่ะ
200 บาทเท่ากันอ๋อ
เพราะว่ากูเอกต้องส่งบางทีส่ง
กรุงเทพเชียงใหม่ก็อาจจะ 10 บาท 20 บาท
เนาะค่ะเดี๋ยวทักกรุงเทพฯญี่ปุ่น
กรุงเทพฯที่ไหนมันแพงใช่ค่ะตอนนี้ก็เลย
เป็นออนไลน์อ่ะอ่าส่งออนไลน์เท่านั้น
โอเคเขาว่าถ้าใครอยากส่งการ์ดปีใหม่
ก็เขียนเขียนเขียนเขียนการ์ดแล้วก็เอา
การ์ดใส่ซองจดหมายอ่าเราก็จะส่งจดหมาย
เวลาเขียนน่ะเขียนปีใหม่ใช่มั้ยปีใหม่วัน
ที่ 1 วันที่ 1 นะใช่ค่ะที่มีวันที่ 1 นะ
คะอ่ะวันที่ 1  1
มกราคมมกราคมใช่ค่ะเราเขียนอะไรคะ
สุขสันต์วันศุกร์หนังสุขสันต์วันปีใหม่
สุขสันต์วันปีใหม่สุขสันต์ก็ยิ้ม
สุขสันต์วันปีใหม่ใช่ผู้หญิงก็สุขสันต์
วันปีใหม่ค่ะผู้ชายก็พูดว่าสุขสันต์วันปี
ใหม่ครับขอ
นะเอา
โอเค
ก็ต้องมีมีที่อยู่ใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะต้องมี
ที่อยู่ด้วยนะคะนักเรียนเฮ้ย
เฮ้ย
เตรียมจะลบอันนี้ยังไงนะ
ได้ไหมก็ได้ได้ๆอะลองดู
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
นก - ๆโอเคมียางรถยางรถยางรถอยู่ไหน
พี่ทียางลบ
ยางลบ
ขอบคุณค่ะคุณเอ๋
หลังรถตลกที่เขาได้ไหม
ฉันคิดว่าน่าจะได้แล้วอ้าวเป็นรอยเลยที
นี้ไม่ไปให้โอเคไม่เป็นไรล่ะไงอะห่อ
ละ
โอเค
ไม่เป็นไรอ่ะ
ที่นี่ก็จะมี
ที่อยู่อันนี้เป็นกล่องใช่ไหมคะถึงเรียน
วาดกล่องไม่ตัวก็ได้หรือจะให้พี่จะสกรีน
คะเรายังไงอ๋ออันนี้ก็ได้น่ะได้เอ้อโอเค
มีกล่อง
เห็นอยู่เนาะเห็นค่ะเก่งมองเข็ม
เคขยับนิดนึง
มีกล่องแบบนี้
สี่เหลี่ยมกล่องสี่เหลี่ยมนะคะ
โอเค
ที่เราเรียกกันว่ากล่องพัสดุใช่ไหมคะฉัน
ว่าเราจะเอาของขวัญใส่ในกล่องพัสดุเออ
แล้วเค้าจะมีกระดาษไหมคะ
กระดาษ
ของเยอะมาก
ก็เป็นกระดาษที่ใช้แต่กลับไม่ใช่กระดาษ
แบบนี้นะคะเป็นกระดาษสำหรับ 8 ใช่มั้ยหอ
เอามาแปะบนกล่องแปะแบบนี้ใช่ไหมคะตัวเอง
ไงค่ะ
[เพลง]
แล้วตรงนี้เราต้องเขียนอะไรคะ
เขียนและเค้าจะมีคำว่าส่ง
ส่ง
ส่งนะคะมีผู้ส่งหรือเปล่าคะ
นี่มีผู้สูงจะอยู่ข้างบนก่อนไหม
กูส่ง
มาส่งข้างบนผู้ส่ง
ใช่ค่ะหนูส่งแบบตัวเล็กๆ
หมดเล็กนะคะนี่
ส่งกล้าๆเรียม
หอเขียนเรียงถ้าเป็นผู้ส่งหาเรียมก็จะ
เขียนว่าเขียนในนี้นะคะค่ะเดี๋ยวเอามา
เขียนให้นี้
เรียงใช่ไหมคะชื่อเรียง
อ๋อแล้วก็
บ้านบ้านบ้าน
เล็กมีอะไร
บ้านเลขที่ของเรียมสมมติ
รถที่
151 แล้วก็
ที่ไหนคะอยู่ที่มหาสารคาม
อำเภอ
ได้เหรอคะ
โอเค
มหาสารคามสารคาม
[เพลง]
ค่ะ
ใช่
แล้วก็
มีรหัสไปรษณีย์ให้แลนไทย
ส่งในประเทศไทยอ๋อเขียนเขียน
มหาสารคามโอเคโอเคเขียนอ่ากรุงเทพฯ
โอเค
นี่แต่ถ้าเกิดส่งไปญี่ปุ่นส่งไปอังกฤษส่ง
ไปแคนาดา
เตรียมก็ต้องเขียน Thailand นี่ประเทศไทย
ได้ค่ะประเทศไทยมากรหัสไปรษณีย์
ชายค่ะไปรษณีย์มหาสารคามรหัสไปรษณีย์อะไร
คะมหาสารคามรหัสไปรษณีย์ 44000
มีวิธีไม่เห็นใช่มั้ยขยับนิดนึง
[เพลง]
เรียนเล็กลงและ
4  4  0  00 นใช่ค่ะเป็นรหัสไปรษณีย์
รหัสไปรษณีย์อ๋อแล้วผู้รับอยู่ตรงไหนคะ
ผู้รับอยู่ตรงนี้ค่ะ
ผู้รับ
ผู้รอานผู้รับศพมุดสมมตินะคะก็ลองอันนั้น
เรียมจะส่งให้ครูเอ๋
ใช่ไหมคะเตรียมก็ต้องเขียนชื่อครูเอ๋
ใช่ค่ะเตรียมก็จะเขียนชื่อครูเอ๋เอ๋
คุณ
ครูเอ๋อยู่กรุงเทพฯค่ะกูเรียมตัว a อยู่
อยู่บ้านเลขที่เท่าไหร่คะอ่ะครูเอ๋อยู่
บ้านเลขที่สมมตินะคะ
อ๋อ
สุขุมวิทถ.
สุขุมวิท
นิด 52 มือนะคะอ่าสุขุมวิท 52
รัชโน
พระโขนง
อันนี้สมมุตินะคะนักเรียน
ไม่จริงนะคะสมมติ
อันนี้เขียน
มาถูกไหมคะไม่เห็นค่ะ
โอ้วเรือนกระดานขึ้นเรื่องอะเรือน
และขนมคนเดียวใช่ไหมคะโอเคโอเคอ่าหนูจะ
เป็นกะ
ชเล hks
[เพลง]
โขนง
โหน่งอันนี้ถูกไหมคะโอเค
กรุงเทพฯ
[เพลง]
รหัสไปรษณีย์อะไรรู้ไหมคะเรียงไม่รู้ค่ะ
กรุงเทพฯพระโขนง
กรุงเทพฯรหัสไปรษณีย์อะไรคะ
[เพลง]
อ่อน 1
100  260
โม้
ว่าโอเค
แต่ว่าเรียงจำได้ว่าเราต้องใส่เบอร์
โทรศัพท์ด้วยใช่ไหมคะ
[เพลง]
ง้อของเรียนก็ต้องเขียนเบอร์โทรศัพท์ด้วย
สมมติว่า 000
000  000
1  1 โอเค
เบอร์โทรเขียนเบอร์โทรของเรียมแล้วเบอร์
โทรศัพท์ของครูเอ๋นะคะต้องเขียนด้วยค่ะก็
เป็น 2  2  2  2  2  2
ใช่ไหม
โอเค
12  2  2
ติดต่อ 222
223 แล้วกัน
โอเค
สมมุตินะคะนักเรียนไม่ใช่ที่อยู่จริงนะคะ
หนึ่งนักเรียนดูเสร็จอด
1 มหาสารคามมีของขวัญส่งครูเรียม
เรียมไม่ได้รับนะคะ
ของคู่เอ๋แจงลบ
ที่ช้อปฉันเล็กไล่บ้านครูเอ๋
ถ้าอันนี้ก็มีผู้ส่งผู้รับเนาะใช่ค่ะ
เตรียมก็เป็นผู้ส่ง
ครูเอกเป็นผู้รับบุตรดับนะคะครับๆอาเย้
นักเรียนชอบ
ส่งของขวัญมั้ย
ครูเอ๋ชอบเดินๆนะคะๆๆ
สวัสดีปีใหม่ค่าอันนี้ครูเอ๋ชอบเออครู
เรียมไม่เป็นไรมีกล่องแล้วก็ไปไปอะไรนะ
ไปรษณีย์ชะนีไปมีรูปตู้ไปรษณีย์ไหมคะ
ทุเรียนไปรษณีย์หรอคะ
ตู้ไปษณีย์นิดหน่อยอ๋ออ๋อตู้ไปรษณีย์
เดี๋ยวเลี่ยมหามีไหมเมื่อกี้เห็นกูเรียน
เมย์มีค่ะ
A มาแล้ว
รึ
หน้าอันนี้เป็นตู้ประสีแดงสีแดงสีแดงตรง
นี้นะคะอ่ะมีสีแดง
เสร็จแล้วไหมคะเขตชีสสีแดงโอเค
สีแดงเป็นปุไปรษณีย์ถ้าเป็นซองจดหมายส่ง
ที่ตู้ไปรษณีย์โอเค
แต่ถ้าเป็นกล่อง
กล่อง
ส่งที่ตู้ไปรษณีย์ได้ไหมคะไม่ได้ค่ะในได้
ต้องไปที่ office ไปรษณีย์จะไม่ใช่ค่ะ
ต้องไปที่ office ไปรษณีย์
ไทยคนไทยเรียกว่าไปรษณีย์คนไทยพูด
ไปรษณีย์
และสีแดงเป็นตู้ไปรษณีย์นะคะแล้วก็เออบาง
ทีพูดสํณสำนักงานไปรษณีย์ไหม
ก็ไม่พูดนะไม่ค่ะพูดไปรษณีย์ใครเสน่ห์
โอเคไปรษณีย์โอโอเคแต่ตอนนี้เนี่ย
ไปรษณีย์น่ะไม่แพงเนาะไม่แพงถ้าเป็น EMS
แทง
ใช่ใช่มั้ย a แล้วก็ m  s อันนี้แพง
EMS  Who ส่งนี่ใช้ใช้เวลาแป๊ปเดียวใช้
วันไหนแป๊บเพียง 1  2 วัน 3 วัน
ถ้าไทยน่ะหนึ่งวันถ้า 1 วันใช่ไหมคะ
กรุงเทพฯกรุงเทพญี่ปุ่น 3 วัน
กรุงเทพฯอเมริกา
จาก 3 วัน 4 วัน
R34 บ้านอีส่ง EMS ใช่ไหมคะแต่ถ้าถ้าไม่
ส่ง EMS  30 วัน
ที่ 5
กรุงเทพฯอเมริกา 30
วุ้นนาการมาก
นาน 30 วันลาตอนนี้นะไม่ใช้ไปรษณีย์ก็ได้
ค่ะเออใช่ค่ะใช้อะไรนะใช้
เพิ่งแชทหน่อยค่ะ
DHL  SL
DSL ก็มีก็มีเคอรี่ใช่ไหมคะถ้า
เคอรี่มี
มีแฟลต 5 อันนี้ก็แพง
ไปรษณีย์ไม่แพง 30 วันโอเค
ใช่ค่ะอ่ะรอรอรอร้องหน้าม้า 30 วัน
เอกลูกเอกก็ส่งส่งไปเดือนธันวาคม
วันที่ 1  1 ธันวาคม 1 ธันวาคมแล้วทูต a
ก็รอรอ
30 วัน
ที่ 1 มกราคมมกราคมใช่ค่ะ
2020 ใจค่ะได้รับ
[เพลง]
2022 ขอโทษค่ะ
022 เพราะว่า 30 วันไปเรือแบบเรือๆ
เตรียมว่าเรือได้ไหมคะได้ค่ะเก้าสิบมั้ย
ทางเรือแบบนี้ใช่ไหมคะเบื่อเหมือนไหม
ใหญ่ๆๆ
มี
อะไรเรือ
เรือที่มีน้ำอยู่บนน้ำดี
ส่งจากไทยใช่ไหมคะใช่ใครที่
อ่ะจะหะรัตน์อ่ะสาขาบ้าน
3 วันเนี้ยเครื่องบิน
โอ้โหต้องเครื่องบิน
เครื่องบินเหมือนไหมไหมเหมือนไหมโอเคไหม
นั้นโอเคนะเนี่ย TG บนฟ้า
5 เครื่องบินอันนี้ก็จะ 3 วัน 3 วันซ้อน
ใช้เวลา 3 วันก็จะแพงนิดนึง
โง่หือป่าวๆอันนี้นักเรียนก็รู้จักของ
ขวัญนะรู้จักผู้ส่งครูเรียมเป็นผู้ส่งใช่
ค่ะ
นะคะ
เตรียมส่งอะส่งมาส่งมาส่งตัวเองรับหากู
เอง
เตรียมก็เป็นผู้ส่งคู๋ผู้รับ
นะที่แล้วมันจะมีส่งกล่องพัสดุใช่ไหมคะ
กล่องกล่องพัสดุแล้วก็ส่งจดหมาย
ว้าว 2 จดหมายนะคะเอ้อแล้วนักเรียนก็รู้
จักที่อยู่ใช่ที่อยู่ที่อยู่
บ้านนะบ้านใช่ค่ะค่ะหาว่คลิปนี้เวลาหมด
แล้ว
เอา
ไว้ส่งคู๋ไปส่งจดหมายขู่เตรียมไปส่งพัสดุ
ใช่ค่ะหน้านักเรียนไปส่งอะไรดีนักเรียนไป
สู่ส่อง 7 นักเรียนส่งอีเมล
ส่งอีเมลครูเอ๋นะคะ
โอเคค่ะโอเค
วันนี้เราต้องลาไปก่อนค่ะเพราะว่าเวลาหมด
แล้วหมดแล้วบ๊ายบาย
บ๊ายบายค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะ
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนวิชานี้